you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is a round
three game from the 2016 Tata Steel
chess tournament between wayy playing on
the white end and Magnus Carlsen this is
a pairing that I've been looking forward
to for about a year now since last
year's Tata Steel tournament we're at
the time way he was playing in the
Challenger section he went on to win
that which earned him the right to play
in this year's master section so this
game here acts as the first meeting
between these two wayy 16 year old from
China clearly one of the most talented
rising stars in our game he is paired
against our current world chess champion
the 25 year old Magnus Carlsen from
Norway let's see what would happen in
this first of many encounters efore e5
Knight f3 knight c6 Bishop b5 entering
the Royal apes' or Spanish game the a6
Bishop a4 this opening has a tendency to
be a bit on the positional side or
strategic side where play is
non-confrontational not a lot of pawn
tension the position does not open up
there aren't early pawn exchanges rather
both sides develop slowly not the case
here such that the position does become
sharp it does does have tension in it it
does open up as early as move 8 Knight
f6 castles Bishop e7 rook e1 v5 Bishop
b3 black castles and after c3 d5 so ok
here we are this is a sharp line in this
opening namely the Marshall attack this
is a gambit line black is with this move
offering up a pawn black with this move
is opening up the position creating pawn
tension and with this line black tries
to show that this backward or
delay in the white development is an
issue eat XD Knight takes Knight takes a
wide snow up upon the Knight takes
Knight rook takes black secures the
Knights post d3 or dozen moves in well
within opening theory neither player
caught off guard well within both
players preparation both players up to
this point have actually gained time on
their clocks they started out with 100
minutes each with the time controls in
this tournament you gain 30 seconds per
move so observing the clock times on the
side for going from one move to the next
does give us some insight as to how much
time is spent on each move now with this
last move in the game d3 this is the
first question I had for myself I have
seen them of d3 I have also seen them of
d4 and until I spent the time
investigating it further you know I
didn't have a reason or I couldn't
identify or share with you a difference
between the two until now
the move d4 I must say to me at least in
I probably for many d4 seems much more
natural why not go to instead of one why
not have a pawn watch over a pawn
instead of devoting a piece to its
defense so what's a difference between
having the pawn on d3 and d4 well let me
show you one difference there's some
tactical idea involved if the pawn is on
d4 it's quite common and this is played
just
in all variations just in this system in
this opening the bishop does reposition
and get on this diagonal with tempo
challenging the rook if the pawn is on
d4 we do have Bishop d6 and the Queen
can come out to h4 after g3 to defend
against Age 2 she goes deeper into the
white position this is a very strong
post for the black queen and one that
light may try to disrupt for example
with rook to e4 trying to play rook h4
to challenge that Queens post however
this can be prevented with the move g5
just super committal move very weakening
move but it does a good job in
preventing rook h4 and it is poison
cannot be captured should not be
captured Bishop takes g5 can be met with
Queen a5 striking it not just one but
two unprotected pieces Knight d2 Queen
takes bishop this is not available if
this g5 move is not available if the pun
is on d3 Bishop d6 Queen h4 Queen h3
rookie for g5 to stop this idea is no
good Bishop takes pawn can be played
because queen of five strikes at only
one not too unprotected pieces anyhow
just wanting to share one of the
differences between these two okay so in
the game it was d3 Bishop d6 rook e1
Bishop f5 striking a d3 Queen f3 strikes
at the bishop this is ignored black sets
their sights on h2 if white is grabbing
the bishop this is a very strong attack
that black has not a good idea for white
to grab the material development is key
and there's a little of it on the Queen
side
g3 simply parries the threat Queen h3
Bishop III offers the pawn back and it
is taken if white is doing something
other than Bishop to e3 you know as it
stands right now
Black has that direct this direct
connection between the rooks the thing
that we look to do when we play to have
all the pieces cleared out between our
rooks White is two moves away from
having similar if Knight d2 is played
white is still two moves away from
finishing development the knight still
has to move and the bishop still has to
move so white is offering up the pawn in
order to complete development Bishop e3
within Knight to d2 is the idea that
white house black gets that material
back white finishes development and now
black plays Queen to f5
I should mention that on Bishop to e3 it
isn't a good idea for black to say you
know what I'm going to take this
opportunity to grab the bishop pair and
they takes Bishop because white can
recapture move forward improve the rook
position prepare to double and have
security over the d3 pawn that pond will
live white will maintain that pawn plus
not a good idea to take the bishop in
this position as soon as it plays to e3
nor is it a good positioned a good idea
to take the bishop after Knight to d2
Knight takes here is also not a good
idea because after rook takes the bishop
is hit and white can next take on c6
with the Queen Bishop g6 Queen takes c6
the development on the white side is
fine and white has still that pawn plus
some care of course needs to be taken
over this weaknesses near the Kings side
but not a good idea to be taking
Knight takes bishop there only after
Queen f5 is this now some threat Knight
takes bishop black is preparing to
exchange Queens which would rule out
that earlier mentioned Queen takes c6
move and only then take the bishop so
black threatens to exchange Queens and
then take the bishop with this last move
so white gets out of the way only at
this point
Bishop d4 there is no Knight takes
bishop the rook is now unmasked rook 88
King to g2 improving the King position
slightly Queen takes Queen King takes
you could take with the knight but it
may be a little bit uncomfortable you
know this is the thing that I think
about when if the knight is recapturing
I see a move like Bishop to e4 and I see
that I'm in a pin and I can't resolve
that pin so easily you could resolve it
in time with something like rook a 1 and
then Bishop to c2 but you know just to
recognize some of the uncomfortableness
that's he from the word some you know
the discomfort let's say that Y can
experience if they're taking on f3 with
the night instead of the King so in the
game it was King takes Queen rook to e6
and if we observe the clock times
Carlson has spent very little time in
fact you know this last move it seems
like it was played pretty you know
pretty quick and probably within his
preparation still here and I'm
highlighting this because it may have
influenced this next move by white it
seems it may seem appealing to just grab
this rook it does allow this discovered
check but you move the king out of the
way and there's maybe you know it is
this
a liability you know something that can
be exploited having now this isolated
pun well things can get quite sharp from
here so if white was not prepared if
they have not seen this position before
if they have not looked at it before
with computer it's it makes them sense
to not go in this direction into the
sharp line where black is throwing some
punches and you know if you're not
careful you know things can quite easily
go bad my point here is Carlson seems to
be with this last move the more prepared
side so entering a sharp line maybe not
a good idea and this is a sharp line so
we don't have this capture on e6 but
instead rook A to C 1 which is prepping
this c4 move the c4 move can be played
right away this is important question
you might have and pointing out well
rook a c1 is preparing this well why not
just break with c4 right away you have
enough support for it if we look at c4
right away this is a move the idea with
this can be to you know try and disrupt
the knight position if pawn takes this
would be this would be good for white
because the bishop can recapture and
what is the end result of the b-pawn
being exchanged for the C pawn well
black now has some deficient queenside
structure to isolated pawns black
however can actually move the knight and
have this move in mind for example after
C takes B the rook is hit but black
doesn't have to react to that pick it
play a takes B and allow the rook to be
captured because after the recapture
there's a check if King G to Knight see
two wins the material back this would
not be the case that there
was on c1 it gets a little bit more
involved from this position after king
to e3
there's moves like c5 and black playing
a line where they're in exchange down
but they have very active pieces I don't
want to show that I don't want to go too
far astray from the actual game but
that's those are some of the points this
night b4 reaction in reply to c4 right
now instead of after having the rook on
c1 okay in the game we did have rook a
to C 1 not this c4 strike black now
plays a6 or to me h6 this is a flight
square for the black King I should also
mention this rook a to c1 move does not
allow this quite natural doubling on the
e-file this is you know if we have a
look at this move the move played was
this h6 but if black is doing something
supernatural like rook F to e8 doubling
rooks what can follow is the exchange of
rooks and then this c4 move and this is
very good for white not a winning
advantage but there is some a white is
definitely the preferred side here with
this variation the knight is hit if the
knight moves right away now this is no
good
C takes B there aren't those tricks of
Bishop takes rook and then the pond
recapturing with check in this case this
is an issue for black so you actually do
have to take on c4 right away you can't
make a knight move and after Bishop
takes Bishop takes Knight takes it can
only be white who is fighting for you
know white is the preferred side here
for what reasons well structural
standpoint Queen side these are
deficient to isolated Queen side poems
if you want to take it one step further
compare King positions this is a better
King position this is an endgame the
Kings want to be closer towards the
center this is a a better positioned
White King okay so the natural rook F to
e8 not a good idea instead H to h6 still
having this idea in mind where if the
rook is captured in some way there is
this recapture with the discovered check
like it's out of that altogether tucks
the king away King g2 rook g6 gets out
of the line of fire the bishop for one
and places the pawn in a pin which is
now permitting a Knight f4 check this is
something that white allows Knight e4 is
played about 18 minutes were spent on
this move Knight to e4 a continuation
that was likely thought about in this
position was the bishop for a knight
exchange this is a big deal in the game
just yet in any chess game the bishop
for Knight exchange is a big deal big
imbalance to try and assess white could
have gone for this to give up the light
square bishop for the knight on d5 and
then look to next quickly eliminate this
trump that black has which is to say the
bishop pair by playing Bishop to e5 if
the bishops running away you could look
to try and hunt him down in this way if
he's avoiding the exchanges these pieces
can take up some nice posts this is a
direction that the game could have gone
the bishop for Knight exchange I imagine
that was at least one of the things one
of the variations that was considered
here to take the knight and then find a
good post for this night he would have a
good square to rely upon in that of the
d4 square he did not go for this instead
improves the knight position and strikes
at the d6 Bishop allows Knight to f4 and
this does hit Knight f4 check King moves
forward
Bishop takes Knight rook takes Knight d3
striking it belts rook and pawn you move
the rook and defend the pawn right you
could do that but white instead stays
very active with the rook centralizes
the rook rook to d1 allows the pawn to
be captured rook d2 so this is a good
post for the rook it's an active post
striking at the night he's on an open
file
White is now down upon has however the
bishop pair well centralized rooks in a
better King position in this ending
Bishop a3 to defend Bishop to b6
clearing the rook to maybe enter here
along well rook to d7 is an idea but
also it's clearing the way for the rook
to observe these two jumping points by
the night rook to d6 takes rook Bishop
takes rook to e2 night to d3 if the
knight is immediately going here we can
expect a quick capture and then the rook
getting very active rook to d2 Bishop to
e5 to e2 Bishop to d6 this may also even
be an idea going straight in for rip to
e4 instead of questioning the bishops
position like this of rook to d2 to e2
simply rook to e2 hunting down this pawn
like this rookie for rookie 4 to c4 so
Knight c4 was not played Knight d3
instead rook d2 Knight to e5 hitting
with a check King goes back to g2 Bishop
e7 that Bishop was hit by the rook now
f4 you know Knight does not have very
many options he goes into c4 going to
let's say g4
yeah this lets the rook enter strike at
the bishop light will likely grab one of
will likely regain the material and
still have these two bishops in an open
position not a good idea not a good idea
for the night to play to g4 or even g6
for that matter is just as good on g6 as
E is off the board so Knight c4 Bishop
takes Knight pawn takes there's been a
lot of back and forth here with one side
being up material then giving it back I
mean how did it play out so far black
played the gambit line light was up upon
like gave the pawn black black was up
upon and then black is basically giving
the pawn back here in each case there's
this you know when you're up the pawn
your pieces aren't as well positioned
you're kind of on your heels and then in
order to get off of your heels you give
that material back to release the
pressure and that continued to shift
back and forth like that from white side
black side black side to white side we
had that little shift going on in many
cases in this game so far as it stands
right now black is up upon it's not a
super healthy pawn of course but it is
upon a situation of double isolated
pawns here but White has rook activity
to a real comparison here white is also
on move playing rook to d7 Bishop f6
rook c7 Bishop takes erupt take C black
is step upon but the White has rook
activity better pieces rook to b8 a4
Bishop to b2
Bishop to a5 number one priority get rid
of this past pawn c3 Bishop takes Bishop
takes rook takes rook to b4 and now how
to react to this pressure against the
pawn well it's a five that is the best
move rip to a3 on rook to a3 black and
play a5 and be one step further and one
step closer to queening should this pond
fall so first it's best to play a five
and only then rook to a3
if this pawn is captured at least this
guy has to work a little bit harder to
get his to get to his desired a1 square
so a5 in other words when the pawn is
hit a 5 only at this point rook to a3
rook check the King moves forward
you could play back here but it's a
little bit scary to have your king cut
off from the action white is instead
moving forward at 5
Rick c3 looks to transfer the rook looks
to also win the a6 pawn so black needs
to get back to a position where they put
pressure on the pawn does that after
Brooks c3 rook b5 this is the best way
to put pressure on this pawn if you're
doing it by way of a to the replace to
c5 and this is a much more active post
for the rook to defend the pawn when you
compare that with the rook playing to a3
this is far more defensive this is a
better post defense and he also has some
aggressive intentions from c5 so after
this rip to c3 move it is rook to scuse
me rook to c3 rook beef
five is played next rook to a3 g5 f
takes h takes King to g2 King g7 h 4g 4
and now white says I'm not just going to
stay here and defend my pawn I'm going
to allow you to take it and while you
grab that material I'm going to improve
my rep position rook c3 rook takes a
rook c6 cuts the King off rook check
King g1 a5 white gets right behind the
pawn a4 King h1 black is up upon him
started out early where white was up a
pawn but we had that auto back and forth
the shifting of material the shifting of
piece activity King h1 king f7 there's
not a good way forward for either side
here white stays around here with the
king and the rook stays on a6 ideally
placed to be behind
he's ideally placed because he is behind
the past pawn and he is cutting out the
king from moving forward king h1 a3 king
g1 and it is at this point that the
players agreed to a draw there's not a
good way forward here if black is trying
to improve the King position towards the
center he will have to first go in this
direction but this is not such a good
idea if black is trying something like
this we could play king h1 and as soon
as the King plays here then actually
yeah after the King plays here we could
push h5 and the King will not be able to
stop the pond so guess who's going to
have to do that the rook and when he
does this pawn is taken even if we have
this exchange of the H pond for the a
pawn this will not be enough to win this
is an easily holdable draw for white one
pawn versus two so there's really just
no way forward here black could give a
check after a to like after King to g1
if black is giving a check King g2 and
then playing a to white can do basically
whatever just keep the King sitting here
and keep the rook trained on this pond
like this if the King ever gets down to
this point where he is defending the
pawn you could just give a check and
then get right back over here to keep
pressure against the a to pawn but
there's even more serious issues that
black hat would have to tend to in in
such cases there this is a connected
passed pawn so there's really no way
forward and again after this Kingdom she
won move move 60 players agreed to a
draw so interesting first encounter
between these two what are your thoughts
on the future of maybe these two players
battling I was looking forward to this
game I know it ended as a draw not the
result that most players would really
like to see usually like to see a win or
a loss of some decisive result but yeah
interesting game between wayy very young
talent and our current World Chess
Champion Magnus Carlsen so feel free to
leave any feedback as usual to this
video and as usual I hope you got
something out of it that's all for now
take care bye
you